welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question
this is a podcast that gives you too
much information about how our biggest
heroes are also our biggest idiots
and had they made the obvious smart
moves countless lives could have been
saved
though you know the world would have
been a lot more boring
i'm eric boss with me is zach huddleston
welcome back to the show man
thanks for having me back eric voss i'm
excited i'm
slowly going to get inebriated i've been
looking forward to this ever since the
last time you made the mistake of
letting me on
speaking of mistakes that this is the
real mistake you letting me be
this is a mistake episode oh no maybe
we'll see where it lands in the list
like we'll decide in real time maybe an
honorable mention
okay all right what's this week's big
question eric this is a question we've
gotten a couple times and it often gets
brought up during our watching
which avenger made the dumbest mistake
the biggest mistake the worst mistake
i love this question um because if you
think about the mcu is full of mistakes
all stories
are based on mistakes that's what makes
life interesting
we don't make mistakes we have happy
accidents you know
you could say it's always a mistake to
trust loki or to experiment with gamma
radiation
or to recruit peter parker to fight with
grown-ups but you know those mistakes
are worth it they make them see you a
better place
at the end of the day you know they
define the mistake maker's destinies
thank god we had those mistakes
but some decisions were so
inexcusably short-sighted and
frustrating
stupid permanently devastating that we
have to discuss them we have to learn
from these mistakes
because they completely defy the
character's intelligence level and they
lead to
needless violence these aren't just like
oh a story needs to happen someone needs
to make a mistake
these are ones where like no we already
saw you in history
learn this lesson why are you still
making this mistake so those are the
mistakes we're gonna we're gonna talk
about those are the mistakes we're gonna
address
us in our in our height seats just
looking down on these superheroes right
in judgment right
who are we to judge what would happen if
we were given these cosmic powers
would we make the right choice i feel
like if i were to snap if i had that
glove i would just get like
stacks of cheesecake factory cheesecakes
but just like four of them
just for it'd be like oh i didn't know i
could wish for more and the big smoking
and fried while i'm
chowing down on some raspberry swirl oh
yes
all right uh let's start with the the
first one
on our list we're gonna we're gonna rank
these start with like big ones and then
work our way down to like what i think
is the worst one
all right so first nick fury messed with
the tesseract and opened the door to
loki
so we're gonna widen the scope of
avengers to all marvel heroes how about
that so here's the mistake zach in
avengers the first avengers in 2012 nick
fury used project pegasus and dr eric
selvig their whole team to experiment
with the tesseract in an
open day portal through which loki could
arrive and try to conquer earth now why
was this stupid this is just a normal
mistake because
fury knew what other dangers were out
there after his experiences with the
scroll and the cree and captain marvel
in the mid-90s
and he had plenty of ways to better
protect the planet like he had carol
danvers pager he could have rang that at
any time if he needed help
he had the whole avengers initiative he
knew who tony stark and captain america
were
why did he need project pegasus in
the tesseract to try to fuel these
weapons he was just getting
greedy it was stupid it's a it's a
literal
pandora's box he opened right it's a
cube
he poked it he was like i wonder what
kind of hell this could unleash
and he gave it to dr eric sullivan who
we saw in you know one of his
post-credits scenes he looked in the
mirror it was loki
we never really fully understood what
that meant because joss whedon was just
like
i got my own movie i want to tell okay
so what were the consequences we have to
go through the consequences of this
decision well
i think the biggest one thor later in
this movie said the tesseract
experimentation essentially
sent a message to all the other worlds
in the cosmos that earth was now ready
for a new
higher form of warfare which is a huge
deal because that essentially
put earth on thanos's war path they all
knew
that earth existed but now they're like
oh they're one of the big boys
okay okay we're gonna come take their
infinity stones and kill half of them so
really that was that was furious
meddling that kind of started that
snowball
not to mention the battle new york
killing dozens costing
billions of property damage indirectly
created villains like the vulture and
spider-man homecoming
colson died then was resurrected and
agents of shield but for you know half
an hour there we're like that guy's dead
and then yeah all kinds of damage this
is this is a pretty big one pretty big
one forgivable
but pretty big spy's gonna spy right
he he has to mess with what was already
good enough right that that's
uh yeah the curse and hey uh where would
we be without them than poking that we
wouldn't have had that that lovely
battle of new york that made us all so
happy and
uh made at least one waitress probably
lose a couple days wages
because you know that that restaurant
was shut down for a few weeks to clean
up you know
yeah and that waitress all of her scenes
were cut she was a little girl in
growing pains and she's like hey i'm
gonna be an adult actress i'm gonna have
this romantic subplot with captain
america
nope cut she got one scene at the end of
the movie during the montage of news
reports
and it's all fury's fault all right on
to our next mistake
uh this was pretty big odin was just a
real shitty dad
dad you were never there for me growing
up son
my name jeff so
here's specifically what the mistake was
here so odin created
asgard's worst enemy hela by banishing
her
and even worse pretending she never
existed
he never told thor about her until right
before he died right before she came
back
so this is why this is stupid odin as
you know all father of everyone lectured
thor again and again all about
responsibility
yet he covered up irresponsibly his own
dark history
rather than teach his daughter to be a
good ruler when she was like his second
in command
he like freaked out but she got too
ambitious and he's like go to your room
forever
like sealed up that door and then um
took all the family photos and and
painted
other people over them and then never
told his other kids that she existed
just sharpening all of her daggers ready
to come back and kill them all
worst father so creepy right it also
i mean you have to assume even giving
him the benefit of the doubt
that odin at least like learned some
lessons from his parenting of hella
that then he improved his parenting of
loki and thor
but maybe not if he was unwilling to
even confront the fact that she existed
maybe he just kept making those same
mistakes with loki and thor right
i love you my sons
fight that's right and you know what the
guy's been around for
millennia for thousands of years
you can forgive like a father who had a
kid too young
and he's still a kid he's trying to as
an 18 or 19 year old trying to raise a
kid
and you know he's still making mistakes
in his youth odin is
thousands of years old has conquered
armies
this guy's no excuse to be an idiot oh
boy
so what were the consequences of this
well of course ragnarok asgard was
destroyed mjolnir was destroyed hella
shattered me
she had power over mjolnir that's how
she was able to destroy it
he didn't like specify a subclause of
that charm so that she would be like
removed from the will of that charm thor
lost his eye
i mean i guess you could argue that
ragnarok was destined to happen i think
this is why this doesn't rank lower
but at the end of the day the fact that
asgard was out of the way that's what
opened the door for thanos to start
making his moves and gather the stones
it was
right after ragnarok happened where
vanessa's like oh good no one can stop
me now
and start quickly gathering the stones
stone after stone after stone he
wouldn't be able to do that
if asgard was there to kind of like keep
him in check that's why he waited so
long
but again ragnarok was destined it was
it was gonna happen one way or another
so you get kind of a past worst father
of the year
i i also like your sub mistake of odin
forgot to write a by-law into mjolnir's
enchantment he could have made
he could have made each it was just him
whispering into that into that hammer he
no one was had him on the clock like you
have 240 characters for this one
odin say whatever you want yeah make it
specific bro
whosoever possesses hammer uh shall
possess the
powers of thor but not my first daughter
don't tell thor that she exists though
but if she were to happen to catch this
mid-throw it won't
work and and she'll have to be banished
back oh i ran out of room
on this on this one
[Music]
oh okay i'm going to race it dragon
who's driving
all right let's move on to one of the
biggest idiots in the mcu
peter parker this is why we love him
because he's a brainiac with no common
sense
like most teenagers are this is why he's
so great but this idiot
gave edith to mysterio
huge mistake big mistake big
huge completely avoidable and spreading
apart from home he gave him the
sunglasses
he does it in a bar in europe no good
decisions are made
in bars in europe when you're on a euro
trip and these were glasses of stark
entrusted specifically to peter parker
alone it was
stark's whole legacy it's priceless tech
with the highest security clearance
and he just gave it to this
interdimensional warrior he just
met he didn't consult with nick fury and
uh
you gotta be honest mysterio wasn't even
trying that hard he was like see that
wasn't so hard
[Applause]
it was like the first night they hung
out here's our it's our second
conversation here
take everything that i own it's yours
now stranger
and we know the consequences of this
right well a group of criminals had
suddenly the power to conjure avengers
level threats nearly killed thousands of
people in london
or worse it led to the exposure of peter
parker's identity endangering all of his
friends mj
aunt may and worse we i don't think
we've seen
the worst consequences of this he led
directly to the rise of fake news and
conspiracy theories in the mcu
that could erode everything in this
future going forward
the shocking video was released earlier
today
on the controversial news website
infowars.com
i like this mistake too because this is
the opposite of most of the other
mistakes like this is a mistake of
insecurity and not having enough
confidence or self-esteem right
he didn't think he was worthy of the
glasses like you think like that's a
problem of a teenage superhero
right like not feeling like good enough
or whatever and he gives it up unlike
some of the the cocky jerk wads that
you've pointed out
have made some mistakes on the other end
of the spectrum mistakes of hubris
let's move over to another stupid peter
peter quill this is one he probably been
screaming at this video up until now
peter quill
punched thanos woke him up out of his
trance and ruined avengers inn game for
all of us
so this was the moment where mantis put
thanos in the trance
while the other avengers iron man uh
spider-man were
wrestling that gauntlet we it was so
close we
saw his palm it was just a little bit of
sweat
clinging that uru metal to his fingers
and then just peter quill upon realizing
that thanos killed gamora he lost his
temper punched thanos woke him up
thanos punched him all shook them all
off and that was the closest they got
and they didn't they didn't succeed and
the reason i think this is really stupid
is like
in this movie peter quill had plenty of
time to mourn gamora
right so when thanos took her away from
nowhere he collapsed to his knees
in defeat there was plenty of time to
mourn at that point you move on to the
revenge stage you you're not
mourning you're not like gonna make
stupid decisions anymore you're like all
right we're gonna form a plan
i'm gonna do this you're gonna do this
you're gonna do that and then
we're gonna execute this there shouldn't
have been a time to improvise there and
he improvised
don't you think that's like in all these
like missing children movies
right like all the parents want is
closure right they want a body they want
to know that the kid's not still alive
out there
we'll keep these lights up until the day
i die
if i think there's a chance that will's
still out there
that was the moment right where peter
quill went from like assuming she was
probably dead
and then he went to knowing she was for
sure dead and that kind of closure just
broke him for a second
hey you're absolutely right and you know
what emotionally justified
this was the reason why it ranks so high
and i think some people think this is
the number one worst mistake
this isn't even number one for me is
like the stakes
like peter quill knew the stakes of this
moment
and he gave away the victory this was
like i'm gonna need your help with the
football part of this this is seattle
seahawks
passing on uh you know
yards away from the goal line in the
super bowl and it gets intercepted
yeah did i get it did i do it that was
it
he blew it he blew it you do not throw a
pass
at the goal line when you have marshawn
lynch
all right now let's get to the real big
daddy mistakes
tony stark inventing ultron okay
so the mistake here in attempt to build
a suit of armor around the world
tony stark created a super intelligent
ai that killed jarvis
overtook his iron legion and then nearly
doomed the planet to like an apocalyptic
meteor type event and this was so stupid
idiotic because tony was motivated by
just this irrational nightmare that
wanda maximoff just kind of plugged into
his brain real quick and then he's like
i want to see the farm around the world
but he already like learned his lesson
back in iron man 3. he said that like he
had already retired
he blew up all of his suits like he
learned from ivon vanko that
drones are a bad idea that they're
dangerous yet joss whedon and age of
ultron is like
no he has drones again and then ai's
turning evil that's classic
terminator the war games superman 3.
superman 3's dc i get it but terminator
exists in this universe we learned that
from roadie's speech
and end game this guy knows turbinator
he knows that ai's destiny is always to
like outsmart us and go evil and as a
guy who makes weapons he should know
that
the outcome of those weapons right is
totally determined by whose hands
they're in
and and knowing that ultron exists it's
gonna fall in the wrong person's hands
at some point right or in its own hands
which will definitely be evil
okay let's break down the consequences
of this because they are disastrous
first avenger death pietro maximoff
didn't see that coming
[Applause]
177 casualties in sokovia that included
charlie spencer that was alfred
woodard's son she played miriam and that
led to their whole fight
zemo's family fueling the civil war
conflict
the sokovia accords the disgrace of the
avengers reputations
everything that happened in civil war
was a direct consequence of age of
ultron
the u.n signing of the sokovia accords
that was the setting of t'chaka's death
leading to a bunch of conflict and black
panther age of ultron was so
consequential to all the bad stuff that
happened
and might still happen because there's
plenty of theories saying that ultron
might still be alive
that's awesome sure and it was another
giant trauma for poor wanda maximoff
right like another in a long line of
dominoes that are falling for her that
might eventually snap her magical brain
right
[Applause]
i'm like boom you looking for this yeah
and speaking of her if he didn't invent
ultron oh just think of it
we would have no civil war we'd have no
sokovia accords the avengers would be
ready for thanos but most importantly
we would not have vision and that's why
this ranks so high
is because because tony stark was so
stupid inventing ultron we had to invent
vision two and ruined jarvis who i think
was one of the best characters in the
mcu
and we turned him into one of the
stupidest most boring [ __ ]
in the mcu that's overpowered and and
hurt rhodey
so [ __ ] vision and start for making okay
now
now somebody has to make a reaction
video that's your biggest mistakes in
this biggest mistakes list it's gonna be
pushing your anti-vision agenda just
scroll down to the comments
they're already listing my mistakes in
this video it's fine the second to worst
one many of you
claim this is the worst mistake and i
hear your arguments but to me it's not
the worst
thor didn't go for the head and avengers
infinity war famously
thor spent this whole movie forging a
god-killing weapon nearly dying doing so
and then he'd let his petty selfish
vengeance against thanos get the best of
him he chose
to drive stormbreaker into thanos chest
just to make thanos feel that
pain instead of giving him a quick death
ending the war quickly maybe even just
cutting off his arm
that would have worked too yeah but by
doing so he gave thanos just enough time
and energy
to snap everyone half half of everyone
out of existence it's also
for for you know thanos literally has
bare arms
no helmet on at this point and so where
does he swing the axe
a part that's still covered in armor
yeah
or at least has some kind of he has his
like kind of
thanos tank on you know beach ready
sun's out guns out yeah
and like peter quill thor knew the
stakes of this moment
he knew what it would mean if you didn't
take your time but he did it anyway he's
being immature
however one of the reasons this isn't
number one for me is many have argued
that thor's
aim was off he only had one eye and
there was a specific moment at the end
of thor ragnarok
where he throws something at loki
normally it went right through loki this
time
it went to loki's side and he caught it
showing that his aim was
skewed by his depth perception issues uh
depth reception
doesn't mean right or left he aimed too
low i think he deliberately went for the
chest i don't think it was an accident
well and because he talked a little [ __ ]
while he was driving the axe in there
right what's your daughter say
i told you you died
for that he wanted to drag it out
whereas he should have just gone just
like quill
right like both of them let their
passion for vengeance
take over their smart murder brains so
the blood
of half of everyone a vision well he
doesn't have blood but the gears of
vision
but an endgame natasha tony stark they
stay dead
those deaths are on thor's hands morgan
stark grows up without a father
because of thor's poor decisions wanda
maximon is gonna need therapy she's
probably gonna like rip the universe
apart in one division that's all thor's
fault
at the end of the day it's thor's it's a
lot of people's fault it's thanos fault
more than anyone
but you know uh if thanos did something
wrong
so did thor i mean and also
authoritative price right his waistline
certainly did
oh yeah absolutely and uh that brings us
to
our worst mistake in my view and hear me
out on this
howard stark and peggy carter let hydra
take over shield now this is why this is
such a huge mistake
despite working closely at the core of
shield for decades they were founders of
shield
howard stark and peggy carter failed to
see hydras take over his shield and its
ongoing corruption of all world
political events
you could also argue nick fury maria
hill are also responsible they were
running shield in the later era but
maybe if they had been more transparent
they might have seen it sooner they like
to play everything close to the chest
here's why this was stupid howard and
peggy
recruited arnhem zola via operation
paperclip and they gave him direct
access to their servers now you could
say yes this did kind of happen in real
life the us did recruit german engineers
like verner von braun
under operation paperclip but von braun
was not
in the nazi high command like zola was
for hydra
zola was the number two he was like the
himmler of hydra
he should have been executed at
nuremberg for what he did there were ss
officers
who did far less than zola did who hung
at nuremberg
real-life german scientists who were
recruited under operation paper clip
they were given
close oversight limited security
clearance and then an end game
zola was just wandering around camp
lehigh looking for dr
zola have you seen him that guy should
have had an mp escort with him
at all times i like this because this is
also much like nick fury
a mistake of ambition oh here's the
scientist that can do stuff that we
can't do we got to bring him in
damn the consequences right i mean
howard stark is brilliant this guy
invented like arc reactor technology he
didn't
need him he didn't need zola they
already defeated
hydra and hydra was using the same kind
of tesseract tech that he now had
he didn't need soul for that is there
any evidence right like some people have
made the argument that like
nasa we wouldn't have gotten to the moon
certainly as quick as we did if we
hadn't
you know let those nazi scientists help
us or whatever right is there any
evidence that zola did
anything to benefit shield or the us
beyond
uploading himself into a computer
that'll live in a dot matrix uh world
forever
he was spending a lot of time doing that
that he wasn't spending like fixing the
world's problems right
uh so far no now maybe we'll learn in
some future that zola was instrumental
in uh darpa
and creating the early years of the
internet doubtful
i mean howard stark was way ahead of
this and you know what when we uh
recruited
verner von braun we were in a cold war
with russia they were recruiting just as
many scientists they could get their
hands on
and there was a space race there was a
ticking clock there was an arms race
the u.s wasn't trying to they didn't
recruit zola to try to beat the soviets
they were getting greedy again they were
getting greedy and the reason i think
the stakes are so high on this one the
consequences
project insight nearly killed millions
of people
and it was a matter of seconds that
captain america was able to switch out
those drives
and then hydra in that movie was hinted
at to be behind dozens of worldwide
terrorist events
financial crises millions of lives
ruined
millions of people died potentially
maybe 9 11.
we didn't see footage of the towers get
hit but it was implied that like
terrorist events were all hydra's fault
and then eventually yes howard and maria
were killed by that hydro winter soldier
program
led to the avengers dissolving and
fighting in civil war
leading to them being unprepared in
infinity war so ultimately
hydra's takeover of shield was poisonous
to the heroes of the mcu in so many ways
that we're not even talking about here
it was all because they recruited this
one evil guy
that they easily could have just let
burn though shout out to toby jones
one of my favorite character actors oh
he's great he's got such a weird looking
head
i love that guy that to me is the worst
mistake in the mcu i think thor not
going for their heads pretty bad but
it's also a bit understandable it does
not make any sense for those two shield
operatives to have been fighting that
battle on captain america the first
avenger and then recruit the number two
hydra loyalist to give them the keys to
the kingdom yeah so there's there's all
kinds of other mistakes i want to hear
what other mistakes you think we left
off in the comments below but but those
to me are the top ones yeah how many of
the comments are going to be they never
should have made a captain marvel movie
hey that we're talking about in-universe
mistakes we can't speak on behalf of
kevin feige
all kinds of mistakes were made there
you know edgar wright and we we can go
on and on but first before we continue
with some bite-sized questions that
zach's going to answer
we want to thank our friends at coors
light for helping us make this episode
so it's no secret that this summer is
pretty different
lots of things we normally do during the
summer aren't really happening
but summer itself is not cancelled zach
coors light wants to help you chill this
summer take a break from the stresses
and pressures of daily
life and i am a big fan of coors light
my
father's family is from colorado so i've
been tapping the rockies since i've been
of legal age
i i enjoy it's a smooth refreshing
flavor
i'm not hanging by the pool or going to
the beach this summer
i'm rarely did that even in a normal
summer but like you and i
have participated along with some other
folks in like some zoom game nights
where i've definitely cracked open a
cold coors light to enjoy that even
though i'm just staring at my
laptop it's it's been it's been nice
there have been times where you know
we're playing werewolf and everyone
thinks
i'm a townsperson but they think i'm the
werewolf or
or the mafia or whatever it is and i get
voted out early and then i just have to
sit and wait and watch people's reaction
for about 20 minutes
crack up on one of these and uh i'm good
to go i think
i think your reputation hurts you eric
in games like mafia or werewolf
because you're always taking notes and
people assume you're so smart
that you're playing 3d chess and so they
always want to kill you first
they're like whatever he's doing he's
taking this too seriously he's gotta go
it's the same reason why a lot of movie
theater ushers throw me out they're like
what is that idiot fiddling with i'm
like i'm just taking notes from my
youtube channel
and they're like get out of here so the
new coors light summer
can does the work for you it features
sunglasses that literally turn blue when
the beer is cold and ready to drink
it really is the perfect beer for
chilling as it's cold crisp
really just 105 calories which is crazy
so that is why coors light is the one i
choose when i need a moment of chill
so when you need a moment to reset the
summer reach for the beard that's made
to chill
you can have coors light delivered by
going to get dot coorslight.com
and finding local delivery options near
you celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company golden colorado
my can's extra big because i like how
small it makes my hands look
tiny tiny all right we also want to
thank audible for sponsoring this
episode listen to the new audible
original the sandman
based on the best-selling dc graphic
novels written by neil gaiman
which were hailed by the los angeles
times magazine as
the greatest epic in the history of
comic books and i'm
inclined to agree neil gaiman is amazing
so i'm so excited to check out the
sandman's audio version
on audible this audio adaptation is
decades in the making stars professor x
himself james mcavoy in the title roll
follow morpheus the dreamlord as he's
pulled up from the dream realm and
imprisoned on earth
and when he finally escapes he must
restore his power to rebuild his
dominion that's
just a start it's featuring powerhouse
ensemble cast including riz ahmed
kat dennings michael sheen and more in
your wildest dreams
you've never heard anything like this
listen now only on
audible go to audible.com the sandman
okay now we're going to move on to some
bite-sized questions that zack is going
to answer for us you ready zach yes
ready to take a bite so first question
can captain america's shield be melted
so this this is a good one and we don't
have a specific
person that asked this question but
we've kind of seen similar ones pop up
on
twitter and patreon discord before and
it's a good question because
we've seen cap shield damaged right like
phantoms hacked it practically in half
we also saw
uh t'challa put some kind of scrapey
marks in it but we've never seen it like
melted and when you're dealing with a
metal
right well in theory at some point it
had to be forged right it had to be
maybe in a molten state so can it be put
back into that molten state
and of course as you've done videos
recently about the shield
in the mcu cap shield is made of um
vibranium
alloy right that howard stark um cobbled
together with nothing but a hammer and a
box of scraps back in 1940 whatever
right
now and that's very different than the
comics where it's made of
proto-adamantium
and so like i'll talk about both a
little bit because we know a lot less
about it in the mcu version obviously
the shield's been around for decades and
there's been a lot of story lines
that have rotated around it in the
comics in the movies
we we don't know we don't know exactly
how howard stark was able
to forge that original shield with the
entire world's supply of vibranium
outside of wakanda
which what a terrible use of a precious
resource
oh use it for eddie just use it for
bullets just yes
you know uh a hundred bullets you could
sell each of them for
two million dollars at least yeah
instead just a big throwable discus
uh but whatever hey i'm not here to
judge that's your job eric voss
part of the explanation that might make
sense for the mcu that it's not
meltable right and how he was able to
forge it to begin with
we can kind of take from the comics
right in the comics
basically the original shield was forged
with a little bit of science a little
bit of magic
[Music]
the scientist who was making it fell
asleep and when he woke
there was a shield somehow this problem
we've been trying to solve for a long
time
just was fixed as he was asleep his
wizard roommate cobbled it together
while he slipped
yes and he was never able to replicate
it after that right
so maybe there's a little bit of that
with howard stark right like it's early
early days of 20th century science
there's all kinds of whiz-bangs and
gizmos and whatever
somehow it magically appeared never able
to reappear right
but now it isn't true also in the comics
proto-adamantium
in all adamantium has this special
property that basically
once it's turned solid it can never be
melted ever again
so it can be like melted down a first
time
and then after that like once it's
coated logan's bones
or once it's formed into cap shield
that's the form
it's always going to be and no amount of
heat like even human torch going nuclear
heat can melt it back to a liquid form
but
there have been obviously again a ton of
comic book story lines
and the shield all kinds of crazy stuff
has happened to it in in general anybody
that can manipulate
like molecules or reality can mess with
the shield
not through just getting it crazy hot
but just you know if you're distorting
um
the quarks or whatever that make up the
shield so somebody like
a molecule man yes it won't get um you
know
ever melted because it's it's super
special unobtainium
but like there is some equivalence in
real life and i just want to point out
again
the adamantium uh vibranium connection
that you've talked about before
in x2 william striker right
when he's quoted talking about the
weapon x program
where they put the adamantium onto logan
wolverine right
the tricky thing about adamantium is
that if you ever manage to process its
raw liquid form
you got to keep it that way keep it hot
because once the metal cools
it's indestructible so again if we
assume that vibranium
in the mcu is kind of the equivalent of
adamantium
in the comics then great there's your
answer can't melt that sunbitch
good answer all right next question is
there a real-life tony stark
and could he afford to make that tech
okay so of course there's not a real
life tony stark and thank
damn god right we don't want to do an
indestructible metal suit with rockets
and [ __ ] okay
but um there are some people and and
specifically our
most recent are ncu tony stark right
john favreau and robert downey jr when
they were developing the character for
iron man 1
they had meetings and interviews with
elon musk
and they based at least some of his
character
on elon musk who at the time this is
right so he wasn't tesla elon musk he
was uh
you know spacex paypal elon musk but he
already had
a bit of a cult following as this like
rogue entrepreneurial
dude and so like yeah elon musk has some
of the same qualities right like
he's both like super rich he's also an
engineer he builds flame throwers
right he's kind of obsessed with um uh
different forms of power
electric cars right space rockets um
arc reactor right yeah a little
equivalent there um
and and of course he's also a
billionaire or at least like a hundred
millionaire he's pretty rich
um but if we're just saying like people
who are wealthy enough and maybe crazy
enough to pull off
like tony stark level stuff forbes
magazine did this thing where they
estimated
the net worth of like fictional
characters like bruce wayne and
professor x whatever
and they guessed that tony stark was
worth about 12.4 billion dollars
which is an absurd amount of money right
but yeah
you know how much money jeff bezos is
worth eric oh way more than that right
114 billion almost 10 times as much
jeff bezos could afford to be like 10 10
tony starks which we should all fear
that and maybe a good reason to not shop
at amazon
i don't know there's not it's not a
liquid 114 million right or billion it's
it's [ __ ] up in amsterdam yes but he's
crazy wealthy or even like
larry ellison who's another super rich
tech guy who
also came out in iron man 2 along with
elon musk that's right
yeah and like has some very tony stark
ask uh facial hair
there's some look there that's very
expensive facial hair
yes that's only billionaires can afford
that kind of a cropped
rotate uh but larry ellison even he and
he's
further down the list of top
billionaires he has 59 billion so he's
like five times as rich as 20
though i will say one thing that a lot
of the richest people in the world
have going against them is they're all
like in their 50s or 60s which
i know robert downey jr is not a spring
chick especially by the time he gets to
end game
but you know you still got to be a
decent athlete to be flying around and
fight
those bad guys so really the only guy
that maybe has a chance
just with the combination of youth and
absurd disgusting wealth
is mark zuckerberg who is worth 89.6
billion dollars
um seems to be probably a putt
[Applause]
but um you know hey he's still got a
year a couple years ahead of him
robert downey j you know tony stark had
kind of an arc
of maturing and working for the greater
good maybe zach will do the same thing
i don't know we can hope we can pray and
hope
that he's just at the beginning of his
three-act journey yeah he's still in the
first five minutes of his movie
okay the social network is like 18 hours
long
okay so we have now come the time for
our final box of scraps
question
and this week oh we've had this one
before so this one
says what is a mistake that you regret
making on the internet that can never be
erased
zach we are having another round
of find my shame
so we're gonna tell our stories we're
not gonna give you all the details
but uh it will be on you to try to find
the shame on that exists somewhere in a
dark corner of the internet
zac what do you got i probably went
through
six blogs in two years
i would be very excited for the first
you know four or five posts
and then just you know my enthusiasm
would wane i'd get
80d distracted do something else maybe
i'd finally get a girlfriend and that
would take up the uh
latent energy that was just uh pooling
around my ankles
i started a blog that was just dedicated
to the slurpee machines of greater los
angeles and what flavor was available at
what location nobody was asking ooh i
need that
i need to know which ones have the
frozen cokes and which ones just have
the dumb fanta flavor
right and there's nothing worse than
when you go and you're excited and you
get a slurpee and it just comes out wet
mush because it's not frozen enough
right because they don't care yeah i
still want this as a service maybe it
should be an app on a phone
and not an old school 2008 blog
but right like there should be a service
where because there's a 711 on every
corner in los angeles but like oh
drive the extra one mile because this
one has the good flavors and it's cold
and frozen right
all right that's interesting shame i
want people to find zack's uh slurpee
blog
find zach shane find it and then
um all right so here's my shame because
i've given you one shame this is another
shame and
it's interesting they bring up facebook
notes and blogs because my mistake is
both permanently online in blog form and
in ink and zach i believe you know the
story i
sabotaged a candidate for student body
president in college
because he was an [ __ ] to me on
facebook i knew you didn't you planted
that story about the chicken i didn't
plant the story about the trees
seriously what the hell is the chicken
i'm not proud of it but i did it
and here's here's the story of it so
zach and i went to the same college
in florida and we were part of the same
improv group and uh when i was a
freshman i wrote this facebook note
that stirred up a bunch of drama between
our improv club that we were both part
of
and then this other club that was like a
theater club that we
we you know did stuff with but we really
had a beef with but i i wrote this
note and i was kind of i was real snarky
and i was talking [ __ ] and i thought i
was being real funny but everyone
commented on it because i didn't set my
facebook to private i
just created it so it was at a time on
facebook where like anybody was on
facebook
could find my account and read the whole
thing
and so a lot of these theater kids were
really pissed off at me and i knew all
of them
and they were all like kind of friends
of mine except this one guy and we're
gonna use
a pseudonym for him brent dorman um
and this guy i never heard of him before
but he
assassinated my character he began his
comment by going
listen scumbag he called me like
worthless
uh and somebody words he's just like go
[ __ ] yourself delete your account that
kind of thing
which this is just my first random
internet troll i have gotten plenty of
those since then i'm so
used to this but i never forgot his name
because i had no idea who he was i'm
like who was this brent guy
i later found out that he was dating one
of my theater friends at the time
she introduced us at a party she goes
this is brent and she tried to get us to
like talk and hash it out and we were
both kind of like
no we're good nice to meet you but we're
good i don't really
want to even talk about this so fast
forward ahead
two years i had risen up to become
the humor columnist for the local
newspaper
which basically someone just knew me who
was like an editor there they're like oh
he's kind of funny
i was terrible my column sucked most of
it was just like gross dumb ideas
and our the editor was like what is this
it would like trim it down and be like
i think this is kind of funny there was
a particular week where i had no ideas
for a column but then i opened up this
newspaper and i kept seeing all this
praise for this guy
brent he had made a name for himself
rising up the ranks through our student
government which was
way too big of a deal at our college um
he was now running for student body
president
he had a reputation as being this
outspoken progressive
champion um he was like the first like
non-fraternity candidate in years who
actually had a chance at winning because
like
everyone kind of knew his name he kept
getting in the paper for stuff or like
speaking on behalf of these different
things marching with protesters
and uh i mean this this student
government was dominated by
frat row and the greeks um sororities
and fraternities
uh and just because they had ways to
like kind of rig it
and historically it has launched plenty
of political queries i believe marco
rubio was in
the uf student government uh yeah so it
was a big
florida blue florida blue key is the
equivalent of skull and bones at the
university of florida
and like every senator and governor from
the state of florida
has been a member of florida blue key i
had a brief brush with them working on
our homecoming
at the university and i i know and
they're not evil they're just hard
drinking fraternity people but
yes continue well and zach you ran for a
student body president
for a brief period i did or joke of
a full joke candidate but yes i did i
got i got in the paper a few times for
doing that yeah well this guy brent was
like a man of the people
you know he was just he was not just
running on the left
progressive party he was running to the
left of the left all those sg
student government friends who i knew
were like we can't stand this guy
he talks down to everyone he's so
pompous he's smug and i'm like
i think i had a social media brush up
with this guy
so i had this platform in the form of uh
this column
and zach this was kind of like my
hamilton burr moment you know where like
uh what nearly one president hamilton
spoiled it
by saying jefferson has my vote here's
the deal i needed a column i was on
deadline
and i knew he was an [ __ ] and i'm
like this guy is a piece of [ __ ] he's a
troll
and he got away with it so here's what i
did i wrote a column dedicated to him
and i spilled all the tea zac i i uh
quoted
everything he said to me i said this is
a guy who's trying to ask for your vote
right now this is the kind of person he
is
and i was just kind of joking it was a
humor column so i was joking like
finally i have a reason to vote like
we're all like
we have no stakes in this student
government usually now i have revenge
this is great so i i made a whole joke
about that i was really nervous when i
uh submitted it to my editor that night
um because the night before it was gonna
run in the paper student government
uh reached out to us to schedule our
budget committee hearing for
our improv club's first ever budget
approval it was when i
ran i was president of the club at the
time and i promised them that we're
finally going to get funding for our
trips and our workshops and stuff like
that
um they the meeting got delayed and
delayed pushed
late at night after 10 p.m which scared
me because 10 pm is when the online
version
of the next day's paper went up on the
website and
a week this is a week from the election
and like i'm you know everyone's looking
at
our newspaper every day and then i walk
in the room
and brent is on the committee of eight
people i had no idea he was on this
committee
so i am checking my my phone i'm
looking at the time and then i know the
online version of this article is up
and then i see him he's checking his
phone as like other people are getting
you know pitching their stuff and then
like at one point he looks at me
and he kind of like does one of those
and then finally i do my whole spiel do
my song and dance
and then it gets approved it's
preliminarily approved he votes to
approve
he's just kind of like yeah sure gay um
so the next day the article goes out
30 000 issues spread all over campus my
phone blows up my facebook blows up the
article's a hit
um everyone i know in politics was like
you got him thank god finally someone
can call this
this white night out for the [ __ ] it
really is it like i don't know how big
of a hit it is it just seemed like it
was it was the most hits
any of my stupid columns got and someone
told me that pita pit which is like the
pita
fast food place they clipped it out and
they taped it to their window
i guess like this dude had pissed off
the guys to peed a bit at some point
so they're like yeah
[Music]
so then at like an hour after i wake up
i get a phone call
it's this dude it's brent i don't know
how he got my number initially but he
told me
he got it from our opinions editor so
the opinions editor was not my boss
it was my boss's boss my boss was the
entertainment editor didn't care about
politics i thought the article was funny
she's like go with it but her
boss was the opinions editor who did
care deeply about politics
was very friendly with this brent guy
she actually wrote the opinion piece
endorsing him
so he tells me it was i was shocked to
see her call him
um because i had never heard of you
which [ __ ]
just saw me last night but whatever um
but
mostly i'm surprised that your editor
failed to fact check it
um because i never wrote that comment
and i would have been happy to explain
this
um had anyone reached out to me and in
fact while i investigated it on my end
um one of my friends
from that time has come forward and he
said that
that night um when i was with my then
girlfriend we were all talking about
the um that controversial article you
wrote
and he took my open laptop when i wasn't
looking and he commented under my
account
no i was like you [ __ ] liar
he was
excuse yep he said he got hacked
uh and then he said he will be emailing
you soon
and then immediately i got an email from
this guy as if he was in the room
and hit send upon his cue and uh
and the other guy was taking basically
word for word exactly what he said i
don't even know if this guy exists
because i could not find him on facebook
which is crazy
back in this year everyone in college
was on facebook couldn't find this dude
on facebook anywhere
and then he drops the kicker he says i
was just surprised
you would post this after i supported
your improv club at the budget meeting
he was a threat he was threatened
because my budget was informally
approved it had to go to the full senate
and someone could veto it or delay it or
like
take it out of the final budget that
went for approval so here's the problem
i had no way of knowing what the truth
was i had two people who could come
forward and say i was a liar
so here zach is where i made my mistake
here is my shame that you can find if
you look hard enough
since i was worried about the funding
for our improv club just being blocked
uh you know me pissing off everyone in
my club i agreed he made this request to
me i agreed to
write a follow-up to the paper's
opinions editor that would run the next
day
so i wrote this up i made it real jokey
i just kind of updated people on what he
said what his claim was and how like
it's possible to know the truth
and really all politics is [ __ ] and
this has gone too far and like
trolls are gonna troll you know it's
like making a bunch of jokes well the
next day
this is what happened the follow-up ran
but
the opinions editor shortened it by half
she took out all my jokes and it was
buried on the opinions page underneath
another article
that was three times longer a letter to
the editor
written by brent she didn't tell me that
she was gonna give him they
she put our article side by side to say
let them you you decide who was telling
the truth
his article denied my claims he called
my voter apathy corrosive to democracy
just like oh god uh and then at the very
end
you know okay my response just a three
paragraph noodle
where uh it was it was my relative to
the editor but i didn't write the
headline to it
the editor wrote this headline brent
dorman didn't write comments
making it look like i had apologized and
i had like retracted what i said
which is not what i said at all they
completely mischaracterized what i said
but i couldn't complain i couldn't do
anything
because according to the opinions editor
she was my boss's boss she could
just like let me go i want to keep this
humor column because i want all these
clips so epilogue to this
brent lost the election by a huge margin
he came in a distant third which is
probably gonna lose anyway i don't want
to take credit for it
and then i recently looked up this brent
guy and he's now a labor lawyer in new
york he is like
fighting the good fight thank god for
this man he's doing just fine
i i want to leave uh this episode with
two pieces of advice
if you're over the age of 21 drink coors
light if you're under the age of 21
never be a jerk online people will
screen grab it
it will come back to haunt you even if
it just even if you're just at a party a
year later
and you have to confront the person that
you are a jerk to or whatever it does
not
bring joy to your life you will be a
happier
better person if you avoid being a jerk
online talk [ __ ] in person
never type it out that's that's my
advice and if you do type it out
eric voss will remember your name
and write or post something that will
drag you
and you cannot claim you got hacked
because it worked on me once
shame on me find my shame
well that is her show it was so great to
chat with you zach
and stroll down memory lane into all of
our shame and skeletons in our closets
uh a reminder to all of you that you can
join our official discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
new rockstars you can get an audio
version of the show by subscribing to
our new rockstars big question podcast
wherever you get your podcast and you
can send us your big questions
on twitter by using the hashtag
bigquestion or by mailing us at our po
box you can follow me on instagram at
eaboss
follow zack zhuddleston on twitter and
follow me rockstars on socials
and subscribe here on youtube we get too
much information about the stuff you
care about and
over long stories about the petty
battles of eric's college i love your
memory for this [ __ ] i
barely remember two years ago you have
like a photographic memory for every
experience you had in college i love
that
i never forget anything it's my gift to
my curse
[Music]
you